as Luke Skywalker said this is not a
heap of jug this baby is the Gargamel
chamber
it looks of it not an amazing piece of
equipment now but back in 1973 this did
something quite remarkable what it did
was I discovered neutral currents
yeah Gamal named after Hubley's
legendary giant wife of gargantuan okay
so normally you know you think of what
makes something moves typically it's
some sort of interaction right something
to actually make something move so you
know the kind of things that we we know
of that will do that will be some sort
of electric interaction or magnetic
interaction to electrons you know go
past one another then they'll they'll
repel and so they'll move however if
you've got a neutral particle passing an
electron something we know no
electromagnetic charge you wouldn't
wouldn't expect anything to happen
except when there's another interaction
involved and that other interaction is
called the weak interaction and that's
what was measured inside this chamber
back in 1973 it really is a piece of
history this this the experiment that
went on in this machine actually won a
clash off Weinberg and Salaam the Nobel
Prize in 1979 what happened in is
they've got a lot to thank thank this
machine for the body of the Gargamel's
chamber is a huge Ken container four
meters 80 long in one meter in ninety in
diameter its construction required a far
greater precision than that needed in
conventional boiler making so we're in
the science garden in San where there's
a lot of little bits and bobs of
equipment and some of it's just been put
together as art this is obviously its
original original thing this this used
to weigh 25 tons when it was full of air
of freon to guarantee good photographs
the inside of the chamber has to be
painted with an absolute photographic
black against which the film slender
strings of white bubbles and out clearly
it's in a terrible state this is
disgraceful there's like bacon right and
I believe this was why they came along
here to celebrate a lot but this is a
and this you don't want to touch that
there's a cigarette butt down there as
well
it seems to be disappointing really that
they
get to this state when this is really
scientific history an epoxy resin paint
was used it was applied by an operator
wearing a special heat proof suit for he
was working in a chamber heated to 120
degrees centigrade at the time of the
experiment back in 73 this was full of
liquid freon and then they passed some
neutrinos through it and there were some
electrons knocking around now if you
just had the usual electromagnetic
interaction not that would happen that
neutrinos got zero charge it's not gonna
do anything to that electron okay
there'll be a gravitational attraction
between the two but that's tiny that's
you're not going to observe that so you
wouldn't expect anything happened except
Weinberg and grashof and Southland
assalaam predicted that something would
happen that there would be this this
neutral currents between them but
basically this neutrino and this
electron will exchange what's called a
dead particle okay so that's that
particle would go between the the two
objects and it would cause the electron
to source of juda a little bit forgive a
little to wiggle around a little bit and
that happened that was seen in here
basically they they threw loads of
neutrinos through this thing to make
sure it happened and the electron
started to wiggle and that was proof
that because we knew there was no
electromagnetic interaction that was
proof of it of a new type of interaction
taking place inside this this machine
it's the weak interaction it happens in
the Sun okay it's what makes the Sun
glow so you know what happens in the Sun
for example is it a neutron will decay
into a proton and an electron neutrino
that decay process comes in the core of
the Sun it's essentially what makes the
Sun glow that that process is
essentially due to the weak interaction
it's a weak process in front there is
enough room to allow the chamber body to
be set up
what Weinberg glass java and salam did
they merged electromagnetism and the
weak interactions together in a unified
theory called electroweak theory
Yaya will cost 25 million francs or
close to 5 million dollars so Gargamel
is the is the mother of gargantuan
rather late 16th century books on Giants
and so it is pretty big it certainly
weighed a lot it was 25 tons at the at
the time of the experiment so pretty big
object I did say what didn't look as big
as I thought it was gonna be there it
doesn't look like 25 it's a bit
underwhelming where you actually save
her scientifically it's definitely a
giant for what happened in here but for
the selection of the photographs nothing
can quite replace the eyes of the
scanning girl in a hunt for the tracks
of the whimsical neutrino I've talked
about the weak interaction that that's
this other force and what that does is
that's mediated that's comes from the
exchange between two particles exchange
either a W particle or a Zed particle so
they're different types of particles
they're new particles were talking about
here the W for the W particles called
the W because it's related to the weak
interaction the Zed particle was called
the Zed because as a as Y bug has said
since it was the it was the piece that
completed the story so it's like the
last bit of the story so that's why he
called it instead